[Music]
this week on booknotes our guest is
phillip short former foreign
correspondent for the london times the
economist and the bbc
he joins us to discuss his recent book
mal alike
philip short author of mao a life who
was he
an extraordinary man
who was actually many men
uh poet visionary
military strategist
philosopher not of not a terribly good
philosopher it has to be said
a very sensual man who liked women a
very ruthless man a man who was above
all marked by
quite extraordinary determination the
will
to dominate the will to succeed
he was several men and he lived several
lives compressed into one long life of
his own but he also compressed immense
changes in china
over a very short period
china when he was born was a
a feudal empire which hadn't really
changed for
2000 years when he left when he died it
was
a great power a major power a member of
the un security council
with satellites with intercontinental
ballistic missiles with nuclear weapons
it was a modern state
how long have you spent in china
i first went to china in 1977 i was
based there for the bbc until the early
80s i opened their office there uh and
then i've been back
for periods of oh up to a couple of
months
pretty regularly ever since um
almost every year for the last decade or
so
less often in the previous previous 10
years
this is a big book close to 800 pages
yeah
is there is
is there a new
new material in here oh there's yes i
mean the point is there has not been a
new biography of mao for 20 years the
last one uh the last major biography was
ross harold's
in 1980
and over the last 20 years
so much has emerged i mean facts
documents memoirs by people who were
around mao
that huge areas which we didn't really
understand or we understood wrongly are
now much much more clear
it's possible i think for the first time
you say it's a long book yes but he
lived a very long life and a jam-packed
life full of
of of adventure and excitement and ideas
and and you know in a way he he lives a
life of of a character in an epic novel
and um
there there was so much to put into it
because now one has the information to
draw a rounded portrait where it really
wasn't possible 20 years ago how long
did it take you
six years
i i was working on other things i mean i
had to earn a living with the bbc for
some of that time but
yeah it was six years of research and
the last two two and a half years doing
nothing but
is your wife's name ren quan
chuan and is that a chinese name yes she
is chinese yeah and where did you meet
her
i first met her actually in in beijing
peking
in
1979 um during the the democracy
movement that happened then there was a
great sort of outpouring of
of uh free expression
and uh wall posters criticizing this and
that it was it was a little bit like
1968 in paris so we first met then and
then 10 years ago quite by chart ten
years later i should say i met her again
in paris
and you know once is uh silly but twice
you can't do much about it
and what role did she play in the book
she played a very major role uh in two
ways um
my chinese is is you know like a
a six-year-old it's it's it's um it's
not wonderful
um so she went through
reams of documents with me and
for the all the trips that i did
interviewing people and going to places
she was with me she was instrumental in
that
and also
because she is chinese and she has a
whole network of chinese friends it made
it vastly easier to talk to people who
would not
normally have talked to a foreigner
you know the chinese are becoming much
more outgoing they're becoming much more
willing to
to uh
discuss sensitive topics privately not
publicly but privately
but even so it makes an enormous
difference if you have
how do i say blood ties if you you know
if you are chinese or you you have a
network of chinese to go through how
many years was he the ultimate total top
power in china
well 49 1949 was when uh
he proclaimed the people's republic and
he died in 1976. so that's 27.
but in the communist areas he was
undisputed leader really from
let us say 1937 38
late 30s what year was he born
1893
so born in the last century born under
the empire
given a very much a classical education
you know he was made to learn great
chunks yes that's him that's him at
uh the age of about 17 or 18.
it's the earliest photograph we have at
the time of the revolution the
revolution which overthrew the empire in
1911.
and what were the circumstances of the
revolution
well it
the empire had been have been kind of
crumbling and rotting away i mean some
would say for a century but at least it
you know for for the last the last
decades
of the 19th century
and there'd been more and more revolts
some huge rebellions which now
completely forgotten the taiping
rebellion 20 million people died in
china you know
whole provinces
uh uh
best part of
of a century later you can still see the
demographic effects of the slaughter
that was was wrought then
and and this was 1850 to 1816 there was
a big muslim rebellion so the throne was
very torturey
and uh in 1908
the uh emperor guanxi died a child
emperor came to the throne
it's more and more
uh pressure on on the throne
and
the revolution itself started in october
october the 10th 1911 in wuhan in
central china
really in the kind of muddled way these
things often do start
the conspirators
were betrayed
some of them were arrested some of the
others decided to you know to go for it
uh army units were rebelled the man that
they are asked to take charge of the
rebellion to lead the rebellion was so
scared of the idea that he hid and
disguised himself as a scholar wearing a
scholar's gone
but it did ins whereas most of these
things earlier all of these things are
kind of fizzled out this one kept going
from wuhan
it it spread and
mao was was present uh in changsha the
capital of hunan
when that city fell to the rebels
again in a very disorganized fashion he
left a wonderful account of seeing uh
the battle outside the city walls and
the troops storming the gates uh and the
rebels storming the gates and and
bursting in and eventually hoisting a
flag over the the the governor's palace
well actually all that was later
imagination it didn't happen that way it
was a muddle and a mess but he he was
there and he did see the flag lifted
when the the city fell who's son yatsen
sanyat sen is was the first president
son yet
an old old revolutionary um
born i think in 1866 he was the leader
of the nationalists um
and he was the man who became president
of china's first president of the
republic of china
in 1912
after after the emperor abdicated
the the party he founded the nationalist
party
was later to be taken over by chiang
kai-shek
later to be the the great opponent of
the communists the civil war in china
that followed was between the communists
and the nationalists
and uh
under chiang kai-shek to set up a
an alternative regime in in taiwan
uh still in power to this day how big is
china today in population
one point well good question 1.3 million
and how big sorry billion that little
single constant is quite important 1.3
billion and how many people live in
taiwan
around 20 million
um
the the difference is important because
people so often say well look taiwan's a
democracy it is
don't decry the taiwanese achievement
it's it's very considerable but it's
really happened in the last 10 15 years
after chiang kai-shek's death uh you
know he kept a
stranglehold a dictatorial stranglehold
on that island but now it is a democracy
but you you have to think 20 million
people in one island with a lot of
foreign aid
as against
1 300 million people in a huge disparate
country which has always been very
difficult to rule
it's not
you it's apples and oranges you can't
really compare
there is a photo in the book
of the village or it's really not the
village it's the farm the farmhouse the
original farmhouse of uh
mao zedong's father
[Music]
where is this
it's in a place called sharshan which is
oh i guess about 30 miles from from the
capital changsha and
what is interesting
the farmhouse has to a very considerable
extent being reconstructed um but it
it's it's genuine it is as it was
um what's interesting is that it's so
big
you know it's it's uh
mao had his own room his brothers had
their own rooms
it's very
unusual for um a family a farmer to be
as prosperous as mars father was so
mao was not the child of a poor peasant
he was the child of quite a well-off
small landlord
you can see on the map where hunan is
and then where taiwan is right off the
coast
that's right i mean the maps of china
are
in a way misleading because the place is
so big and the map is small but um
hunan in the center just centers south
of china
taiwan off the coast
what was his father like
if we were to believe mao
his father was a niggerly skinflint um
bigoted narrow-minded old tyrant
um and maya was constantly by his own
account rebelling
yes that is a formal picture um
with the little round cap and and the
button and
uh
an apron a lower garment
over his trousers
and a silk jacket he he
who's that right next to him while i've
got the picture there on the other side
on the other side uh the bit next
picture right mao
uh
on maui's on the right of that picture
he's the tall one his mother is sitting
and uh his two brothers
are tan the youngest brother
so so that's that is the mao family he
actually looks quite like his mother his
mother has a very rounded face and mouth
has that same
rounded uh look but no mao was
exceedingly ungrateful to his father
because his father put up with him
you know
my's account his father was impossible
but actually uh mao must have been a
terrible cross to bear as a as a young
man
and uh certainly was constantly
offending against traditional
precepts of propriety and good behavior
the way children were expected to when
was his first marriage
his first marriage was when he was 14
to a peasant girl
it was an arranged marriage arranged by
his his parents and very very little is
known about it she died soon afterwards
mao by his own account refused to live
with her
she um
miss law
died by some accounts three months after
they were married i think that's correct
that's what i
found when from people in sharshan
others say about two years but in any
event
it didn't last according to mao it
wasn't consummated well was it wasn't it
who knows um
and it's something which he has very
consciously tried he tried to kind of
push under the table here's a photo of
his second wife and children
yan kai
yes and the the two little boys and ying
and and ching there was a third child
born and long but he died when uh when
he was young of dysentery
yang kaiwei was the daughter of his
favorite professor
and a man who who influenced him greatly
um a very liberal open-minded man
and they were married in 1920 um the
winter of 1920
and lived together
until
1927. 1927 was when the real clash
between the nationalists and the
communists began
uh chiang kai-shek cracked down uh in a
uh
really a massacre of of communists in in
shanghai
and uh the communists went underground
mao went to the mountains and began the
guerrilla struggle
yang kaiwei stayed with her children
in in changsha
and
mao
then married again um
and he had two wives at the same time
but these these things were kind of
uh looked over fairly tolerantly this is
the
third wife herzegov
um started living with him uh when she
was quite young about 18 or 19 years old
on
the very remote mountain fastness called
jingyang shan
where mao and his guerrillas had taken
refuge
but two years after
mao and herzegovina came together
uh yankai huawei was arrested in a in a
roundup by the nationalist leader in
in changsha
and
executed along with mao's adopted sister
the children were smuggled to shanghai
because otherwise they might well have
been killed as well you know
things were not done by half-measures in
china in those days it was a very brutal
society
children were smuggled to shanghai
they had a very very rough time because
the communist apparatus was was being
dismantled was under tremendous pressure
part of the time they lived on the
streets
and
in the mid 30s went to the soviet union
one of the two children and qing the
younger boy
became mentally disturbed and and
he's still alive but has remained
mentally has had serious mental trouble
all his life
the other boy uh came back
and uh
but we're getting ahead of ourselves in
the 1940s
um came back to to to to china and was
with mao all on and he's got a fourth
wife we might as well talk about her
briefly all right get the women off sure
get through the wives the fourth wife
well herzegovina herzegovina was an
interesting woman
she went right through the long march
with him she bore him children
then uh
she decided she'd actually had enough
about she walked out on mau and he was
he was devastated this is his force
right here on the screen
uh the fourth wife jiang ching
he
started living with
shortly after
herzegovina left him
and uh
he said himself later it was an
extremely bad choice
she was a young shanghai actress with a
dubious past
and uh there were quite strong efforts
made within the party to
discourage or at least cut you know say
is this always this the right thing to
do but you do not tell someone like mar
if he's if he's the party leader of a
communist party
there's no way that you can say to him
well look you can't marry this woman
he'd made up his mind and it turned out
to be really a fairly disastrous
marriage
she had one child
but by
by the early 1950s they were they were
effectively estranged
and later
much much later towards the end of his
life mao used zhang ching as a political
tool as a political i mean he exploited
her
as a political instrument uh because he
knew that she was completely loyal to
him you know the one person who depended
on him completely and whom he could have
complete trust in was jiang ching so he
used her for his political dirty work
put it that way
um she was a member of the gang of four
she was she she tried to use him for her
political dirty work i mean it was not
it was one of these interesting
relationships which is not very edifying
at what point in the remember the year
that they actually married
well
they didn't go through a marriage
ceremony i mean we talked about marriage
mao having been married several times um
i'm not at all sure mao was actually
ever formally married in the sense that
except possibly to his very first
peasant wife in the sense that we were
regarding marriage they just started
living together um
i think he probably did formally marry
uh yankai hue as well the professor's
daughter because i don't think the
family would have you know would have
stood for
for anything different but uh herzegun
they just started living together with
jiang ching i mean they started living
together and they were deemed to be
married when mao invited his colleagues
to a dinner at which zhang ching played
the role of hostess that was it
there is a you know it's rare in 11
years of book notes that there is a
quote in a book that you can't read
because of the language and i think you
know what i'm talking about there's a
quote in this book
that you've got from the doctor
about
oh yes what about
comparing with me troll no no no no no
the quote about what he does with his
private parts uh you know in reference
to women when you have all the women you
know you say you say that that whole
area where you talk about their four or
five women in his bed and yeah
explain that whole
lifestyle that he had and is this new
did the doctor's book the first time we
heard about this the doctor's book is
the first time we've heard about it and
there was some skepticism uh
not in the west i mean the west it was
accepted but in china you had people
kind of coming out of the woodwork and
saying uh yes this enormous this
enormous bed
and you know that is the bed which was
left in my study after his death but
people who knew him say that the bed he
actually used was even bigger
um and if we uh if we believe as i think
we should that he did like to have
several women several young women up to
five young women in bed with him and of
course his books because his books were
important to him and there were always
books on his bed no matter what he was
doing
then a very large bed was clearly
required
look this is
mao with zhang ching
it didn't work this this fourth fourth
marriage
and
you can say it's part of the imperial
tradition i i think it's much more like
in a sense like groupies you know in in
modern
pop music stars or or whatever
mao found that with young women
he could have
a normal contact that was deli denied
now you may question the word normal but
sexual intercourse is a normal human
activity and just about every other
aspect of all mao's activities was
politically regulated or motivated or
had an a hidden purpose this was
something terribly basic terribly earthy
in which
he he had a
human relationship with other human
beings from his point of view that was
it
with his bodyguards who
were young
peasant soldiers
again he had a sort of surrogate family
when any kind of normal family had
you know gone long ago
and i think that was that was his side
of things um
there was also the business he knew he
was getting old uh he had the power he
could do it chinese emperors had always
done it and for the girls themselves
well you know sleeping with god
because that was how he was seen um
probably didn't seem wrong
there are a lot of terms that you use
that we're familiar with i want you just
to tell us what they are quickly so we
can then go back and go over them what
was the great leap forward
a great leap forward was an economic
movement launched in 1958 where maya
tried to mobilize the chinese people to
by by with the strength of their hands
and with their spirit to work economic
miracles backyard steel furnaces
everyone will make steel
grain yields that were you know out of
sight
catch up britain in 15 years catch up
america in a bit longer
what was the
um
august harvest uprising the august
harvest uprising was
we're going right back in time uh 1927
when uh when
the the
fighting between the nationalists and
the communists began
the autumn harvest uprising was the
right the the
failed desperately failed uprising which
mao tried to ferment in hunan
at the time when he he
was starting his guerrilla warfare and
retreated into the mountains
what was the long march the long march
was a very very long march
it was in from 1934 to 35
the communists had a base in southern
china a place called jiangxi
and the nationalists closed in and
had were on the point of wiping them out
when
the communists decided to make a
strategic retreat and it turned out to
be a march of six thousand miles which
took them
right across china to the north west
through
i i've traveled the whole route of the
long march um
and it's a great thing to do if anyone's
thinking of it it's fascinating do they
have it marked
uh no it's not but
the i mean there are memoirs there's an
excellent book by harrison salisbury on
the long march which which has uh a very
detailed account of of where they went
but it is possible now to follow that
route and they went through the most
remote and backward areas because those
were the areas where
the nationalist forces were weakest so
they went you know over the over the
mountains at the edge of tibet through
the grasslands which is a terrible area
of of swamp and bog at 10 000 feet uh
between tibet and and sichuan and
finally down into
what is still a harried desert country
of the northwest which is where they
from 1935 they they made their new
headquarters and what was the cultural
revolution
the cultural revolution was mao's
final attempt to ensure that china
remained on a revolutionary and
ideologically pure red revolutionary
path and of course it failed
um
the first thing i think that i noticed
was how much the russians had to do with
a lot of the early
beginnings there would have been no
communist party if they hadn't
artificially created it in china yeah
absolutely what's the comm intern the
common term the communist international
set up by lenin uh to
you've got to remember this was a time
when russia the soviet union was under
enormous pressure from the western
countries there were white russians
fighting against the communists the
common turn
was set up in order to promote the
soviet union's cause abroad forge links
with workers movements in other
countries create communist parties in
other words what year
1919
the
yeah and so right after that yeah very
soon afterwards and how was it set up in
china
well the common term was based in moscow
and took its orders from moscow um in
1920 the first emissaries were sent to
make contact with chinese left-wingers
and the chinese communist party itself
was founded in
july 1921
in of all places a
girls boarding school in the french
sector of shanghai
otto braun who was he
he was a communist military adviser
a german
his identity was not known for ages when
edgar snow the you know the american
writer went to uh
to to to visit mao in the 1930s he he
met um otto brown but he only knew him
by his chinese name he didn't know who
he was and brown wouldn't talk about
himself anyway in in the the uh much
much much later on in the 1960s brown
in east germany um
started to write his memoirs he was the
military adviser sent by the comm intern
to work with the communists in
the early 1930s
and he
tried to impose
you know strict adherence to russian
military principles which of course
didn't work in china
he he's
often made a little bit of a scapegoat
for the the chinese communist owned
mistakes but
on the other hand he he was a very rigid
orthodox man who was who is not prepared
to do things in a chinese way
i apologize to you and the audience
we're i'm jumping all over the place and
there's just so much to cover here and
i'm not sure that we're getting into it
the right way but you mentioned edgar
snow here's a photograph of him he seems
to be through your whole book we we are
jumping all over the place because this
is edgar snow much later on but he was
he was active but let's talk about it
for a minute yes uh
there in uh 1970 with mao and an
interpreter and on the left just out of
the picture limbia the defense minister
on the gate of heavenly peace and it's
an interesting story in itself
let me just tell it
mao in 1970
relations between china and russia were
terrible there were some serious fears
of a chinese russian war
mao was signaling to nixon
that he wanted better relations with the
united states
one of the signals he used was to invite
edgar snow an american
on china's national day october the 10th
to stand with him and be photographed on
the gate of heavenly peace
to the chinese mind that was an obvious
symbolic way of telling the white house
we are interested in better relations
with america kissinger
confessed years afterwards
they completely missed the signal they
didn't understand the significance of it
at all because it was much too
elliptical
and there were other kind of mismatches
of that kind but to go back to edgar
snow the point of edgar snow is he was
the first
western journalist the first westerner
really to uh to go to the communist
areas in 1936
he went to bauan
which is in this arid desert part of
northwest china where the communists
finished up after the long march edgar
snow went and he interviewed mao and he
produced a book called red star over
china
it is a a basic source because it has
mao's only account in his own words of
his life up to that
point
and snow continued to go back so why did
mal talk to him
because at
various reasons um
mao at that time was affirming himself
as leader of the communist party and he
wasn't
still
undisputed leader but he was
beginning to get there but
more interesting than that the real
reason why he talked to edgar snow was
that
the second world war was looming
the communist policy which was changing
stalin
wanted communist parties to work
together with
non-communists
in order to create an alliance against
fascism well the way that worked in
china
was um
that the the communists made overtures
to the nationalists which eventually
succeeded and they fought in the second
world war
sort of together um against the japanese
but also mao was signaling that first
time with edgar snow that mao was
interested in having better relations
with
anti-fascist western countries it was
all the context of the second world war
how much did mao travel outside of china
very little and it it might have been a
slightly different story if he had
because so many of the early chinese
leaders did
joe and lai dang xiaoping they all went
to france
germany and so on mao didn't
and
the reason in a way that mao was able to
dominate
to
you know out distance all his rivals was
precisely that he was
instinctively
deeply profoundly chinese his roots his
thinking were chinese so he could
respond and appeal to chinese he didn't
go outside china until 1950s uh
1949 his very first journey after
winning power in beijing was to see
stalin he went to moscow and they had a
very difficult time um together
that chinese soviet relationship was
always very difficult
and then he went again in 1957 to moscow
uh when khrushchev was in power those
were the only two foreign journeys he
made
if you followed him around all those
years
what would he
how tall was he
oh i can't give you in feet uh
i'm going to say something you know
bland like was he taller
no no for but remember
chinese
were
less tall on average than americans or
europeans no he was oh i guess probably
we'd be talking about five seven five
eight um quite which means quite tall
for a chinese he's always described and
if you see him in photographs next to
his as very thin and tall and bony as a
young man
um and even eve isn't an old man quite a
lot of bulk
joe and ly
um
john lie is the one on the left john
what lie is the one on the left i think
it's a very telling photograph that mao
is behind the door he's got a very
mischievous
you don't know what that enigmatic
expression on his face
you don't know what that face is is
thinking how old are they here that's
1936
about i would say
so mao there is
43 and joe and lai is
a little bit younger
40. what was their relationship then
what their relationship was
for almost the whole of their career joe
and i was mao's loyal servant
mao used joe
joe did not with one or two very rare
exceptions in the early days joe did not
try to resist
because he realized i think very very
early on
yes that that picture there mao in the
middle with joe and lai uh on his on
mao's right and the third figure
the military commander-in-chief judea
and they were the triumph triumvirate
that
that won power for the communists in
china could mao speak other languages
he tried very hard
he tried he spent most of his life
trying to learn english
um
and he did but he no he couldn't speak
it he could read it to some extent
he couldn't he gave up on russian you
see mao's
mouse chinese was was was wonderful he
had an enormous vocabulary and a
knowledge of classical chinese but his
pronunciation
was hunanese um and marked him out all
his life as from that part of of uh of
china uh he was not gifted with an ear
for languages even his own
this picture there he's uh this is 1949
stalin's 70th birthday
behind between mao and stalin there's
bulgarnin and the bearded man on the
right is east german leader uh walter
o'brien
uh
mao and stalin had a real tussle of
wills on that occasion um
with
basically mao refusing to leave until
stalin agreed to to talk and to talk
seriously about the relationship with
china
but
it it was an ex
for two countries supposedly communists
supposedly allied it was a very edgy
uncomfortable relationship go back to um
go back to that time period when things
started to coalesce
at the at the point when chiang kai-shek
was the head of the nationalists in
china how many people were under his
control
depends when you're talking about uh i
in the early days i mean chiang kai-shek
one sometimes asked you know how on
earth could he have lost china
and the answer of course is
finality corruption and no real vision
of where he was taking the country
but
he had almost everything
you know
90 by 1930
chiang kai-shek had won control of
all of china except for a very few very
small kind of red spots
which were communist base areas
um
so-called because this was where the
communist army would armies and they
were very small they were a few thousand
men that's all would carry out guerrilla
raiding activities sporadic attacks
then
1935 the long march 100 000 people 86
000
figures people like you over but let's
say 86 000 people set out on the long
march from communists
communist leaders and troops
at the end
of those who'd set out only 5 000
survived
in one year
i mean for an army to be able to hold
together in in any sense and continue as
a fighting force losing
95 you talk to the pentagon about that
kind of attrition right they'd say it's
impossible and
it was but they did hold together how
much of that was
they were they killed or how much have
just died of starvation along the way
well a lot of it was um
in the early stages they had some some
appalling disasters um this the early
stages was a long march mao was not in
charge he was
out of power
uh one of the many
times early in his career when he was
out of power
um and at that point they they had some
real military disasters uh
middle of the long march
crucial meeting mao
readmitted to the leadership
you know as an effective leader
um
so
they uh
they did
they made fewer mistakes after that they
still made mistakes but they made fewer
mistakes but they fought 200 battles in
300 days you know i mean it was the long
march was not just a promenade it was it
was a very very difficult uh military
exploit where'd they get their weapon
from the nationalists
uh they captured uh basically captured
weapons from the nationalist side that's
where did the nationalists get their
weapons well from america
initially not initially they got their
weapons by buying them on the open
market but later on as the civil war
really hearted up
they had more more american aid
um very substantial quantities of
american age where are the japanese at
this point
the japanese
we're talking about the time of the long
march okay 19 mid 1930s
when as i say just to go back chiang
kai-shek had control of
virtually the whole of china
and mao had tiny tiny forces but the and
the mouse flat yeah being fed by the
russians all the time with
no no no no
no no
not even any contact of that time not at
that time but they had earlier they had
a lot of contact they had a lot of
contact that they and they in the very
yes in the very early stages they got
financial aid
from russia that was how the party
started going
they didn't get weapons from russia
there was no way the russians could send
weapons you know that
how could they physically get them there
they didn't
um they didn't get money when again
there wasn't
when the base areas the the communists
really started fighting they got no aid
from russia would would china be
communist today without the russians
i'm only hesitating because of the role
the russians played in in starting the
party
they sowed the seed um it was all their
idea
no it wasn't all their idea there were
communist groups in china
already who but what what did they
really i think yes i shouldn't even
hesitate the answer is yes china would
be i mean later on the russians gave
the russians gave very little help all
along the way the the only crucial help
they gave was
actually in the formation of the party
there were already communist groups but
they haven't coalesced
uh to form a party
and
um i i i think that would have happened
with the if had the russians helped or
not
i i you know we're talking speculatively
who can know the answer to your question
but but no it was the whole point about
the chinese revolution is that it was
indigenous it was not triggered from
outside it was not financed from outside
it happened from within the japanese i
interrupted where were they well
you can very well ask if the japanese
had not attacked um had not tried to
occupy china would china have become
communist
that i think is a is a much more
questionable proposition and mao
certainly recognized it
um
years later when the japanese prime
minister visited beijing to establish
diplomatic relations he thanked him and
said thank you very much you know
if you
you helped us to power
and they did why did the japanese invade
because the japanese the japanese were
undergoing a phase of
highly nationalistic expansion in the
1930s as you know as well as anybody
else
i mean you know america felt that too
they initially occupied manchuria and
then they started expanding
occupying other parts of china and
full-scale war between china and japan
was declared in 1937.
now
without that war
to unify the chinese behind a national
cause
to give legitimacy to the communists
because
chiang kai-shek couldn't at the same
time fight the japanese and fight the
communists
it it became untenable for him to do so
therefore he had to make a truce with
the communists the communists then
used that truce to win legitimacy
credibility and to vastly expand their
influence the areas under control under
their control and everything else now
after the war still chiang kai-shek had
after the japanese were defeated he
still had much greater resources than
the communists
but
his regime was corrupt it didn't use the
american aid i mean you've got marvelous
accounts by american military advisers
talking about just how
impossible it was in the late night of
the mid 1940s to work with chiang
kai-shek and the nationalists because
whatever you tried to do the aid was
siphoned off the men weren't properly
fed uh i mean the nationalist army was a
disaster
how many uh i don't know which way to go
with this but how many
people did mao
was he responsible for killing
or torturing or all those stories you
hear over the years in the cultural
revolution how many of his own people
were killed during that
well look
there's a lot of different times there
are lots of different times and it's an
interesting and quite a complicated
question um
i mean the bold answer is more than
anyone else in history
30 million
you know 20 million at least possibly 25
million
20 25 million died in famine
after the great leap forward remember we
were talking about it um this this
attempt to
make china
economically a great power very rapidly
by mobilizing people was a disaster it
led to famine
a famine which was essentially man-made
mao made it
he didn't make it on purpose but his
policies resulted in the famine in which
20 25 million people died
so that
those that he was responsible for then
uh earlier on the in the the time the
communists were taking taking power in
china
there was a campaign against the
landlords the land reforms 700 000
800 000 landlords were killed they were
not killed by mao they were killed by by
peasants seizing the land from them
sorry is that the horse day incident is
that about i mean there's so many no
you've got you've gone way back again
i'm sorry this is amazing how many
different
incidents
i started saying to you this man
compressed you know so many different
lives
into one one person
let me stop here and ask you though how
did you do this how did you do this book
i mean we can't cover
100th of this book in this hour but how
did you
how did you keep track of it all where
did you how did you what was your own
procedure well i did take a long time
doing it and i think that helps um and
it's a subject i've been fascinated in
for years before
so
i mean the the
that's really i think the best i didn't
have any special method but i tried
i tried very hard to
um
to follow to follow seem to to have
uh
kind of vectors of
which would carry you through the book
to trace
trends in his life which you could see
as a young man again perhaps as a
middle-aged man and then again in later
life to give the book a continuity
and that was actually what was difficult
because you know biography is
essentially chronological you know you
can you can follow it but to give it a
coherence
when
he is an actor of
machiavellian duplicity but in so on so
many different levels and on in so many
different stages
stages like scenes you know uh that was
was difficult but i confess
you know it it
absolutely impassioned me i i find it a
totally riveting life
that the man led and i tried to convey
some of that because i think when you're
totally fascinated by something you
usually manage to
convey some with something of your
enthusiasm and fascination where do you
live now in southern france why because
i like it
how long have you lived there
i
when i left the bbc my last post was
here in washington i was washington
correspondent
i went and taught for a year at iowa
which i found very rewarding and
then moved to france we built a house on
a an old stone
say an old stone house a stone
traditional stone house on a
mountainside and why southern france
well
i've lived all my life you know
reporting on other countries i would
find it very difficult to live back in
england now
because you you you develop a different
way of living and france i love the food
i love the language i think the climate
is marvelous and
modern communications doesn't matter
that much more where you live
where did you write the book
ah
i started writing it in tokyo
where it worked as i was based in tokyo
at the time i started writing in tokyo i
wrote some of it in washington i wrote
quite a bit of it in iowa and the last
two-thirds probably in france
with a publisher standing over my back
not so much
henry hold here in the states with my
english publisher with a whip saying if
you don't finish we're gonna put a bomb
on you and
if they took some of your research away
from you what would have been the most
valuable of all this what chunk of
research helped you the most
i think for me the the
most interesting um
because it really is fairly new
is
the discovery that
of how
the communists and mao in particular
turned to violence
in the very early 1930s
in futile
in
in southern jiangxi
because you have to explain you know
these guys mao and the others they were
idealistic
patriotic young men who who really
simply wanted to make their country
strong
and to do
the best they could for it and i mean
it's a very simple phrase but that they
they started out with the best of
intentions
and how did it get from that
to
uh a system which
destroyed millions of people's lives
um which was was totally ruthless
um
and in many ways evil
you know you have to
make that transition and
those events in futile in the early
1930s when mao
ordered a purge and we now know that you
know it was his doing there's a document
which is the smoking gun that
in which
almost everybody who was tortured to
death or killed uh was totally innocent
it was it was a fabricated purge against
a non-existent opposition organization
that was when it really really started
to go badly wrong
in the back you have a list of uh what
do you call it uh dramatus personai yes
uh where you list a lot of people
because of the problem of chinese names
i think you need something to refer to
when you say who on earth was that but
the thing that you list under a lot of
people's names is deliberate medical
neglect
uh what's that referring to in the
cultural revolution
this this is at the end of these little
potted biographies um
how did they die
well a lot of them died a lot yes
a significant number of of mao's
colleagues um those who
he
decided were no longer useful
represented old ways of thinking which
china he didn't want
um
they were
not they were injured
in the cultural revolution by red guards
or by secret police interrogators
and not get an appropriate medical
treatment
i hear you i'm just showing how you
listed a lot of these right
what about the
pronunciation there's a note on
pronunciation to help
it's what can you do
you can't translate the names people
have tried to translate names you finish
up with the lunaces you know if because
a name is a name
my name's philip short but uh if you're
english you don't think short oh yes
he's short you know it's it's just a
name translating is a nonsense uh it
doesn't
enhance understanding and where are you
from originally
i'm british i mean what were you london
born no bristol bristol in the west of
england
and how did you get into this business
what got you as into the writing
business or the bbc of all the time an
inability to do anything else
constructed when did you first get
interested in
when i left university i had no idea
what to do where'd you go to school i
went to cambridge and uh through a
friend of a friend i got a job with drum
magazine in south africa it's a
magazine for
was a magazine for blacks
in the townships
and um i i loved africa
i
then became a freelance in a little
country called malawi
with a very eccentric dictator called
hastings bander and i started working
there for the bbc and the times and
other people and i said i would have
stayed in africa i'd probably still be
there now had i not been expelled uh
repeatedly from one country after
another
and so i joined the bbc
uh you know there'd be no alternative
but to get a profit job
and uh they sent me to moscow
and then to china
you uh say that they wrote this in your
book that mao was a visionary a
statesman
political and military strategist of
genius
philosopher and poet dog in mind
awe-inspiring charisma
fiendish cleverness
we missed anything
would you have liked him
i don't think man mao was a man you
liked would you have respected him
i would certainly have been fascinated
by him
respect
it's almost
yeah it's almost too weak a word i think
i mean he was a giant figure for
good or ill
and
anyone who reads the book will make a
judgment both good and ill you say that
uh he considered his two major
accomplishments to be victory over
chiang kai-shek
and launching of the cultural revolution
how many people
how many people were murdered by these
young kids in the mult a million a
million people million adults yeah
adults and
much younger people in many cases in the
year again of the cultural revolution 66
to
69 but 66 67 were really the firestorm
who led that what what age group
initially
very young um secondary school students
started it and then it went into the
universities the university students
were the main the main force
um
workers groups
joined in and i mean it became horrific
they used anti-aircraft guns on each
other
they beat each other to death they blew
up they made their teachers sit on
dynamite
unlike the fuse themselves
they did appalling things
which is why it's important to recognize
that
chinese did appalling things to
themselves to each other under the
empire and in the early parts of this
century you know it wasn't a sudden
atypical explosion of brutality
it was one might hope a last spasm of a
brutality that had been very deeply
inculcated and again the purpose of it
to
ensure to try to ensure
that mao's ideas of a of a red utopia of
a revolutionary state which would always
be revolutionary and never degenerate
into capitalism as he would have said
that those idea ideas would outlive him
there's a picture that we've seen a lot
in this country that you have in the
book here
of
mao meeting with president nixon there's
henry kissinger over there
what kind of shape was he in at this
meeting
pretty poor
he had uh
in effect a stroke something very
similar to a stroke it was it was a
more complicated condition than that
but uh at this meeting he had just seen
uh he he just purged his defense
minister limbial the next picture
next to it is even later when he's he's
really very very weak 1975 that is his
last mistress chang yufong
mistress
companion in effect by by that stage who
was the companion of his last years
the nixon visit was of what value to
mao zedong
it lined up the united states as an ally
of china against uh the unit of the
soviet union
i mean here we tend to look at it the
other way around and we say the next
visit lined up you know normalized
relations with china um
forged a strategic alliance or alliance
is too strong aware but a an
accommodation a strategic accommodation
with china
against the russians which was nixon's
nixon's logic
in this book your biggest surprise
personal surprise as you were going
through all those papers
gosh
that's something i really haven't
thought of
um
either about him or the periods that
you're studying
i think one of the things
that
has struck me most forcibly you know
there's a there's a there's a view of ma
which says mao was very good in the
first part of his life
then he became
somewhat unhinged detached from reality
and at the end he was a monster
rubbish
it was always the same
i find that vaguely reassuring
this is the book and it's bright red
close to 800 pages it's called now a
life
and our guest has been its author philip
short thank you very much
[Music]
ah
[Music]
for a transcript of this book notes call
1-800-777 text for a video copy call
1-800